it's probably the hardest thing for me
to articulate because most of my life as
a performer deals with forms of
religious music and I certainly feel
that I when I conduct a Bach Cantata
that I am absolutely engaged by not in
an abstract way at all by the issues and
by the stories and the experience but i
can't i can't find a formal structure
for that and when i write a religious
text i would have to say that i am as
gripped by the ancientness and the sound
of the words and the this feeling that
they are carrying significance almost
that has been sort of gradually attached
to them over centuries I would like to
feel that that all of the assertions
were things I can assert and that's not
really how I feel the King James Bible
I've come back to so often for texts and
it it was really translated at a moment
where the English language had an
extraordinary rhythmic and verbal
variety it's Shakespeare's era and I
find sometimes the passage this passage
that attracts me has unusual words or
rhythms that I just find absolutely
irresistible in addition to of course
that's its accumulated significance but
it's as much just a a deep affection for
a text love for a text as it is the
whole world of doctrine from which it
emerges and
like a lot of people who are dealing
with church music can actually work as
the church musician some of the time
it's terribly unsettling to have to
contemplate how much of the conflict in
the world to this day is generated by
religious groups by people who are fired
up about the doctrine and it's difficult
for someone like myself to embrace the
institutional issues having from a semi
historians point of view a pretty firm
idea that they often lead to people
fighting each other